françois et pénélope fillon de retour
devant la justice le deuxième procès du
couple s'est ouvert au palais de justice
de paris on joue en 2020 l'ancien
premier ministre avait été condamné à
cinq ans de prison dont deux ferme
notamment pour détournement de fonds
publics on retrouve votre journaliste
katia technique
saint cassien l'audience a démarré il ya
près d'une heure maintenant un procès
très attendu
le couple fillon s'est il exprimé à son
arrivée
oui absolument tout d'abord pénélope
fillon bien plus combative qu'en
première instance à la question rituelle
pourquoi faites vous appel elle a
répondu j'ai décidé de faire appel car
je ne me reconnais pas dans le jugement
qui a été rendu tout ce que j'ai fait a
été minimisée je n'ai pas pu m'exprimer
comme je le voulais et désormais elle
veut convaincre la cour de tout ce
qu'elle a fait en termes d'activité fort
ce fillon l'ancien candidat ait l'air à
candidat à la présidentielle bien sûr a
répondu qu'il contestait le jugement il
fera une déclaration tout à l'heure
françois fillon son suppléant marc
joulaud et sa femme avaient été accusés
en première instance de détournement de
fonds publics et de recel de
détournement de fonds publics au sujet
d' emplois fictifs de pénélope fillon
entre 1998 et 2000 13 en première
instance leurs aveux leurs arguments
leur preuve n'avait pas convaincu du
tout les juges et même pénales fillon
avait été mise vraiment difficultés face
aux questions de la présidente qui
pourtant étaient des questions simples
et françois fillon s'était montré assez
mordant et sarcastique et aurait au
final et bien ils avaient été condamnés
à des peines de plusieurs années de
prison ferme et avec sursis et à de très
lourdes amendes le couple fillon devait
en outre rembourser plus d'un million
d'euros à l'assemblée nationale qui
s'étaient portées parties civiles c'est
un million d'euros eh bien ils
correspondent ou somme qui avait été
versée par pénélope fillon alors
désormais 15 jours de procès en appel
vont avoir lieu et on commence avec les
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité qui sont posées par
les avocats de la défense notamment sur
la prescription et l'empressement à
lancer une enquête alors que les le
candidat fillon se trouvait en période
électorale
cissé question était transmise et bien
le procès serait repoussé c'est une
stratégie des avocats du couple fillon
met en première instance i vous savoir
qu'elle avait été rejetée donc nous
attendons de savoir ce que cela donnera
cette fois ci ça avec vous merci
beaucoup gâté avec nicky en direct du
palais de justice heure de paris